[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT JONES: I'm Matt
here in Google Chicago.
And Lyft has offered to
pick up one of our speakers
for our dev meetup.
MARCUS WEEMES: This is
Marcus with Lyft here.
I've got Patrick,
and we're getting
ready to take him over to the
Code the Road, Google meetup.
So what are you looking
forward to the most?
PATRICK SKOGLUND: Sitting
down with other developers
and figure out what
aspects they like, things
that they're architecting.
It's good to get
behind the scenes.
I work for a company
called SADA Systems,
and we use Google Maps
APIs every single day.
There's a lot of
individual things
that you can do with
Google Maps API.
So we use Lyft, for example.
I wanted to request a Lyft.
And Lyft has to figure
out a way to identify
what cars are near you, right?
So you use Distance
Matrix API to do
a calculation in accordance
to the road network.
So you're not just
figuring out, here's
a Lyft car that's two miles
away from me, pure distance.
It's, here's a Lyft car
that's two miles away from me,
in relation to the road network.
And that's how it calculates.
But when you look
at Google Maps,
you're able to so many things.
So from a user
experience standpoint,
it's really changed the way that
people interact with things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]